[Musique]
voici militant gay chef et
copropriétaire du tout nouveau resto le
bavard et d'ivrognes à sept îles
on l'a mis au défi de nous concocter une
assiette boréale à partir de produits
locaux
il a accepté et ça donne ceci habitants
non mais avant de goûter retour dans le
temps à la recherche des produits du
terroir de la culture voici bruno duguay
sa maison de la chicoutai a pignon sur
rue depuis déjà qu'ils sur la route là
où tout le monde nous dit qu'il fallait
absolument qu'on arrête de vous voir
qu'est-ce qui est aussi exceptionnel
chez vous à la maison de la chicoutai
ben écoutez vous parle jusqu'il ya
l'idée c'est le bas le bord du chemin
qu'est ce que vous mettez une hallebarde
et j'écoutais on peut pas le dire notre
suite lensoise et c'est une recette
laussucq et c'est bon et des coffres bon
ben on va apporter ça à notre ami chef
pour qu'ils fassent anar léché goûter
est un petit fruit qui pousse dans les
tourbières en région nordique
c'est devenu le fruit emblématique de la
côte nord pour tenir qui en a un peuple
de l'eau la rareté pis les coûts parce
que c'est pas comme les fraises
sincèrement sports mécaniques mais
qu'est-ce que ça goûte pas écouté c'est
ensuite j'ai pu j'ai pas capable de le
décrire à part le côté acidulé niang ou
ben écoutez c'est ce que je dis aux gens
est-ce que la fraise toute la france
ça goûte le scout
[Musique]
on fait un arrêt au grenier boréale une
coque qui osent cultiver des fruits et
légumes dans un environnement peu
favorable à l'agriculture
et ça marche tomates salades bâtissons
ne sont que quelques-uns des légumes
offerts ici
pouvez vous crée un jeu avec les est
magnifique
étienne la chance c'est le grand manitou
de ski cultivés ici ils nous offrent
aussi ceux ci ça c'est de la livèche a
un goût de percer sellerie se mangent
entre les deux ça se consomme près ans à
ramener paix ou dans un seau t il
vraiment sa possession de manière
naturelle où les shebab contre la côte
nord
c'est aussi l'accès à la mer et intel
game de poissons et de fruits de mer à
la poissonnerie du havre ont choisi de
belles petites crevettes nordiques
oui elles sont transformées en guest
physique mais elles sont belles gay
pêcher ici au fumoir le gua niche on
repart avec une grille est au saumon et
un bon morceau de saumon pêché nouveau
brunswick mais fut miss se pétoncles qui
veut nous faire la conversation a été
cultivée par la compagnie pur mère
spécialisée aussi dans la culture de
moule devant une des sept îles on
reprend la route avec pétoncles et al
[Musique]
dernière avait chez de bd de sève
l'entreprise danic la treille
on la trouve en pleine récolte la flore
du thé du labrador surtout l'accueillir
en bordure de mer est quelque chose de
brut dans la mégane i au niveau des
arômes au niveau de aussi du climat et
de l'environnement il quelque chose de
d'un peu dur d'un peu mais en même temps
d'incroyable et diversifiée annick a
quitté montréal il y à 11 ans pour
s'établir ici sur la côte nord le petit
est là mangani mais la fleur qu'on est
kevin tantôt est une des parties de ce
mélange qui est qui regroupe le thé du
labrador le sapin la baie de genévrier
les cdd - saint-gobain 2 on est en forêt
puis ça c'est vosges les que vous faites
nauche les aromatiques ce sont des
gelées d'accompagnement donc gelé de
sapin baumier gelée de thé du labrador
si vous vous avez une proposition nous
faire avec avec cette gelée locale faire
coucou moi ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
faire des crêpes de sarrasin avec
tartiner avec ou le sapin ou le thé
j'aime bien les deux et ajoute une belle
grosse noire de yogourt nature mais la
plus riche le 10 % rien ça fait de très
beau et long déjeuner on a beaucoup de
plantes de bord de mer
la sabline l'épinard de mère le père
ciment avec laquelle on travaille pour
le pesto c'est différent du pesto qu'on
connaît habituellement avec avec le
basilic mais je ne sois plus
rafraîchissant ça + + frais ou vraiment
bon merci pour tout découvert
retour à sept-îles avec notre panier de
provisions bien remplie inspiré le chef
s'affaire à mettre de l'avant les
différentes saveurs et textures de notre
récolte
on est un peuple nordiques on travaille
trois quatre mois par année pour
développer nos produits par marie va y a
plus rien qui pousse fait qu on apprend
à développer des recettes par rapport à
ça la sueur froide avec le bouillon on a
mis le livèche avec le personnel on a
mis champignons crabe de cette île avec
les algues delà de la firme pu remettre
la gelée de thé du labrador
on a faim fusée sa de saumon fumé qu'on
a du fumoir d'aguanish avec les pesto de
personnel on a mis aussi la rillettes de
saumon fumé du monde à garmisch avec son
ami de chou qui renaît boréale et on a
le persil en chiffonnade sur le dessus
un peu de citron puis le sucre et de la
jsa mienne aussi s'inscrire des bouchons
prend un peu de perso ça virage très
polis seul avec la rillette belle
réussite et pour la seconde assiette le
ceviche tongs de la ferme pur mer avec
les crevettes du jour saint piat en
dessous on a mis une statistique on fait
ici c'est ce qu'avait du concours de
l'ail du miel la pistache le persil de
mer et la gelée de shipton c'est
tellement bon le plus le côté sucré ou
écouter avec pépé tant pis les couloirs
sont très belles
ces deux assiettes ne sont qu'une partie
du terroir de la côte nord les gens sont
pas assez habitué à mener porter leurs
produits directement restera valoir leur
propre du locaux qu'elles sont dans
courage des gens qui en ont amené à
nouveau puis à venir développer avec
nous le style de domaine
[Musique]